ciao ragazze allora parliamone alcuni
hanno visto il trailer di una canzone
per te che uscirà il 28 maggio al cinema
adesso per chi non sa di cosa sto
parlando che qui sul buco allora mi fa
piacere ricevere complimenti non letto
pure i commenti però il ragazzo che
saluta quello con gli occhiali non sono
io però l'ho fatto questo film quindi un
pochino mi dispiace per chi ha pensato
adesso chi ha davvero è sì ma serve più
tese credo allora no che vi racconto
tutto perché dallo scorso agosto che
vorrei dirlo solamente che non mi piace
a prendere i cartelloni prima che le
cose siano pronte quindi aspettato
aspettato aspettato aspettato e adesso
posso dirlo faccio parte del cast di un
film si sono sconvolto anch'io però che
dire adesso vi racconto più o meno come
è successo e
[Musica]
sì significa cioè che metà delle
cappelle ma che vogliono questo e
perfino cosa faccia il fiato la giornata
no no vabbè passare su guglielmo si
senti vogliamo fatti male di provino per
un film molto molto guardatelo problema
insomma che ti costa una cosa divertente
no davvero non posso dare il suo cammino
il provino se io che hanno per wal mart
non lo so proprio un po tutte allora mi
raccomando per fare il protagonista devi
saper cantare ci riesci a forti ma senti
cosa ci porti battiato battisti la
canzone del sole porto non su uno dei
tokio hotel
ok il prossimo anno grinta e grinta
grinta per lui solo questo è importante
mette più grinta e lasciate che lo dica
no non è così
la grinta è quinto a moute alex devi
crescere è questo che facciamo un gioco
di crescere e forse era il mondo
facciamo che tu non abbia mai capito il
personale no scusate guardatevi amore 14
lorenzo sono venuta qui prepara di no
non è moccia annuncia federico coraggio
perché più naturalezza palla più vera
davide che cosa vogliamo fare non mi ha
scritto la canzone beh forse arrivato il
momento che cresce pure tu e non sapete
il d'accordo in film come il prossimo
rondolino scrivere
perché il prossimo sexy oddio adesso il
duro nove ragazzi ma dove lo hanno preso
questo nome che mi sono divertito
tantissimo e niente spero solo di andare
a vedere il prima possibile anche se da
una parte sono emozionato
sei proprio ecco lo diciamo che sono
terrorizzato abbastanza
la verità è che fino ad adesso che sono
stati fatti dei provini foto
ora tu secondo me inserti perfetto per
un personaggio lo sapevo simo dai su di
me lo sfigato di merda
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì
[Musica]